what you got there connor what do you
got there connor this is
uh rather odd looking it's like a
[ __ ] whole deli
yes it's just a bunch of uh lots of
bacon it looks like but like
we're about to show off why japanese
bacon
is just one of the worst bacons you can
find in the world i'll try my best to
hold this up without burning myself
okay so this this is this is japanese
bacon here this is a meat platter
as you can see it is floppy and soggy
i just want to show off that this is not
what bacon should look like
or feel like there's two kinds of
sausage and pepper bacon
i mean what are we trying well i'll you
know i'll try the
one kind of sausage i'll try the other
kind then whatever one is
cut one in half actually yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
but what else do you have there in the
meantime jerry okay well i know you guys
have never tried this but
we have nanko ume which is pickled plums
pickled plums uh i you think i haven't
tried that i actually have tried that
okay but there's two different types
because for some reason sydney [ __ ]
loves pickled plums and
i do not know what's the thing literally
i don't know if this is just a
stereotype
literally every female i know loves
pickle pumps i don't know why
like if it's plum if it's like an actual
plum plum flavored thing
yeah is it true like melon do you like
pickled plum
yeah as i'm saying chicks love pickled
plums i don't understand
literally every japanese girl i know
loves pickled plum flavored [ __ ]
boys tell me what kinds of sausage you
would like to have just give me one of
them
i mean this is like a finger yeah it's
just it's basically
they straight up like it looks like a
finger
that's like [ __ ] out of yoshi that's
not of kira's collection
there's one thing that japan just
doesn't do and it's sausages like they
just don't do them right
and like they'll go around calling this
chorizo like that's what they're in
wrestlemania
yeah they will call this chorizo uh and
it should
it's a joke i mean it's literally hot
dog i mean it's just a salsa jay
it's just it's just a it's a sad
frankfurt that's what it is
you can pel you can power close though
with extruding they they they
need something bacon yeah sure yeah i'll
give you guys the p i'll give you guys
pickle plums because we have three
okay so this is actually something new
they you know i'm sure the viewers
watching they've tasted bacon before
they've tasted sausages they've they've
tasted hot dogs yeah what they haven't
tasted
is pickled plums so japan is like kind
of known for its pickleball umebushi
it's called
yeah but basically there's two types of
the [ __ ] there's the
really really sour types of immigration
yeah that's the only one i've had this
is the sweet
mushy there's sweet um this is
this one too yes this is these are all
the sour ones no these are the sweet
ones these are all sweet oh okay
yeah i'll try it so so slightly salted
sweet remember
shit's dripping everywhere yeah watch
out okay let me let me taste this
i know you guys haven't tried this why
does it look like a deflated scrotum
because it's been because it's been
dried basically what do you think
i'm not a fan i'm still on the phone
this is the sweet one this is the sweet
one okay this is sweet yeah
yeah yeah and what universe is this
sweet yeah this is the sweet one so if
you have the sour one it's literally
like ah what what's the what's the most
sour thing you can normally get
in like south it's way it's way more
south you know that one video we did
with joey's channel where we had
the powdered sour just like a bite of
that yeah that's basically
that's basically pickled yeah it's like
there's i bought this theme for my
channel which is pure umebushi extract
and it's considered one of the most sour
things in the world
that's [ __ ] awful yeah it's basically
you start you start salivating
immediately it's one of the most sour
things you can just naturally get
it was really good all right okay okay
my grandma used to hand make these okay
that's why i have like a second i do i
do think there is a lot of at play of
like i am not used to these foods and
although i'm more than happy to try
every single item um doesn't mean i have
to like every single item
no of course what i don't understand
understand about pickled plums
is that why do you like eating something
that sour
like it's so sour it's more sour than
any kind of sweet
or any kind of i don't know like i use i
used to like because
again like my grandma used to like hand
make the umeboshi
and would just sand it in tupperware
right and it's like it is the most sour
[ __ ]
if i had a japanese grandma that made it
for me i'm sure i'd love the [ __ ]
yeah
right i would just come home after
school and just get the tub wear and
just [ __ ] eat it
that's got love in it yeah this dad
didn't have love that had
factories and suffering that tastes like
[ __ ] my grandmother
was your
but i [ __ ] loved it because that's me
off the one bite of eating
um yeah i don't know i love it yeah